they killed me twice with fentanyl
before I stopped using a year ago
does that scare you into quitting
that was enough for me
especially the second time
after a week I died a week apart
oh it happened twice in a week and yeah
twice within a week
I was dead
the first time I remember because
someone had stolen my my truck
and I went down to try and find out if I
could find the person the girl who had
taken it well
I couldn't find her and
got back on the you know
smoking with somebody
and the only thing I remember is that he
handed me a hit
and as soon as I hit it
I felt my heart
gone
and in my mind I said oh my God I'm I'm
getting ready to die
and to myself I was telling him
help me help me don't let me die
help me and then
nothing I just felt cold but to myself I
was I was telling I was like telling
people help me help me
and I found out that my friend she was
coming to buy some crack
and she saw somebody laying down in the
parking lot she didn't know who it was
so she so she said she went to go get
her crack
and then she came back and she said who
is that over there laying on the on the
ground they said that's girly girl uh
but she just faking she all right
she said no she can't be all right girl
he wouldn't be laying on that ground
she said she felt me and I was ice cold
and she's told them somebody give me a
phone call the paramedics call the
paramedics and they told her no call
Grasshopper
which was my ex dude call Grasshopper so
long story short she got a phone and she
called the paramedics they said when the
paramedics got there that they just
grabbed me put me in and I'm out
when I woke up
the doctor told me
that I was a DOA
but the oath that he takes as a doctor
from the time that they called it
from the time that he still had three
minutes in a window
and he took those three minutes and he
he shocked me he said and on the second
shot my heart beat it like I wanted to
live
and when I woke up
he told me and he was like Miss Rose you
are so lucky you really are
and then
a couple of days later
I did the same thing not quite the same
thing a friend of mine's she gave me a
sack and she said here you could sell
this you know you got to rock it up and
you can make some money so I said okay
so my friend rocked it up and I said
okay well I gotta test it
when I took that hit I couldn't believe
it I I said oh my God not again
and I died again
and they were telling him
to take my body
and put it across the street
so that they would not get in trouble
but he said he had my keys to my car my
purse everything because I died
and he called the paramedics and he
stayed with me and he was a dope dealer
and they picked me up in the dope spot
once again and this to the same hospital
and the doctor told me Miss Rhodes why
don't you just give it up
I was like
yeah you're right
so with that I'll give you this poem
it is he that holds my hand at night
when I feel like I can no longer fight
it is God's Embrace that holds me tight
he shelters my body from the cold of the
night
you see he showed me things that I never
knew
and it is God that's showing me that
love can be true
he's laid down the foundation for my
success
he taught me how to walk Tut and dress
you see the person that I am I could
never be so when I give thanks I'll give
it to him because he is my heavenly
father
and with that I'll say post to toast
beautiful as always yeah thank you so
you're no longer working
no no longer doing sex work no no and
and I can't say that I don't miss it I
do not miss it
for a year I think I'm yeah a year how
many years did you do it
over 20. and how many years did you
smoke crack
over 20. you kind of go together don't
they
pretty much you know what that is so
true because after I stopped smoking
it's like I was thinking it was my
um menopause
but it's like without
crap
I don't feel
it's like I have no limbido I don't I I
don't
I don't want sex
I I can't even well your brain chemistry
is probably all upside down from the
crack yeah I
um
guys try to talk to me and I just don't
feel I don't feel anything I actually I
kind of feel like
really standoffish and and
kind of like your first time or
something like I mean the kind of guys
that you're running into down there are
probably not the kind of guys you want
if you're clean right that most
definitely not but I met a guy I met a
nice older guy
but it's like he was too older I mean
you know he didn't have no uh
and you know he had the nice house and
he was really sweet but it's just like
he was missing some
swag or something but I really I wasn't
he wanted to cuddle he wanted to kiss
and I didn't I just didn't feel
comfortable I don't feel comfortable
it's thanks to the Tango right but to me
sex is a money thing
I mean I know and and after you get
clean a lot of people you're gonna have
to get some type of
counseling and I really think that I
should
because
it it seems like it's hand in hand once
you've connected sex and money for for
decades
pretty hard to separate those two it
really is it really is
you feel like uh
I I can't explain it but it just doesn't
it doesn't feel right it feels like
oh I'm not giving it up for free
I don't know how to love
I mean I I can't believe I really still
can't believe that
someone
I guess actually like in love with me
I I feel like
he's just saying that to get the booty
for free
so but there's plenty of guys out there
that are like that yeah but I can
guarantee you that there are other guys
who
that don't connect money and sex or or
you guys shouldn't be there I know I
shouldn't either but you know what it's
just one of those things that you go
through I mean to do something like that
for so many years it takes its toll and
it does there's some damage
you know how can I not really want to
have a boyfriend and and if he ain't
giving me no money I feel some type of
way I mean that's just I know that's not
normal
you'll eventually climb out of this
mindset God he already did the biggest
part the biggest part is done
that when I found a crack pipe an old
one I put my hand take my last breath
I didn't even want to hit it I took it
and threw it in the trash
I'll go to the store I see all the girls
I um I just saw little mama she was down
there and actually I had my last like
two or three dollars I gave them to her
and I just don't want it I guess when I
died
man I I guess I was reborn again and I'm
telling you it is the grace of a loving
God because I never thought I would see
a day when I did not want to smoke the
pipe and it's like I don't even remember
like like you don't even remember you
used to do it you you feel me
that's man God is awesome
I I don't care if you're whatever you
believe in but I believe in a God that
saved me and I do not no longer smoke
crack cocaine now if he can take the
bottle from me I'll be doing some magic
and I post a toast because I'm telling
you I gotta have a toast
but I love everybody that loves my
poetry and
I really do I think that at the end of
this at the end of this journey
I think I do I wanna
have a little book or you should do a
little social media page where you
recite your poetry yeah yeah
you know like every day like prolific
like every day an open diary
like every day
um what it what it takes me and what I
what I encounter with other people and
myself and getting back into my family
because that's gonna be the hardest
thing in the world
now that brings me anxiety
because I have not seen my kids and
[Music]
maybe 12 years
10 12 years it's a lot of damage from
that lifestyle
and I've yet to see
um I see them on
Facebook and um I talked to him a little
bit on the phone
but I'm always trying to I want to like
hurry and hang up because
I feel some type of way
so I've been thinking about just going
ahead bite the bullet
move out there to Vegas where they are
before I go to Mississippi
and you're moving to Mississippi that's
what you told me before we started my
grandmother my my grandfather
that they had the 47 you know when they
gave them 40 acres in a mule where my
family kept ours
and the family out there paid the taxes
on the land and so now we have 47 acres
in Madison Mississippi
how do you change your life oh God I
don't yeah so
um I guess the end of this journey I
told you
I I saw it I I really did I felt it
felt it somewhere in my heart I didn't
know how it was going to happen
and it took death but I didn't see no
light so
I'm supposed to be right here
yeah so I hope everybody when I do get
my channel
um well you'll help me along with that
what to do and pretty soon I'll be right
out there I mean I'll probably start
posting tomorrow
you go because I need something positive
to do with myself
and
it's something I do well so yeah you
sure do
all right
girly girl thank you so much for coming
back
thank you and gracing us with a little
more of your poetry
I'm happy for you thank you you don't
see a whole lot of stories of people
recovering from from these lifestyles
down
you don't and I know
I tell oh I know
I don't it it it had to be when I died
because I do not feel
I used to wake up in the morning and I
had to have a hit
I'm running around on the street I I
felt like I needed a hit
and I cannot explain to you that I can
wake up in the morning
and I don't smoke crack cocaine
it's a power greater than myself
so the first step is right
that you used to go there is a power
greater than yourself that will restore
you back to sanity
they did not lie about that
good for you
so to everybody
post a toast because when he get the
bottle away from me I won't be the baby
all right thank you darling love you